something really weird is happening with evangelicals in this country
and we don't totally know why
hi I study the far right with an emphasis on Christian nationalism
to understand why this new phenomenon is so strange
you have to understand the two major
trends of religion and politics in the American landscape since like
the 1980s the first one is the fusion of the Republican Party
with evangelical Protestantism
it's hard for us now to imagine a world in which this wasn't the case
but this was a political development and a political tactic chosen in the 80s
as churches in the south
who were running their segregated academies
were losing their IRS tax exempt status
they responded by getting involved in politics
it was not because of àbôrtîôn
they saw àbôrtîôn as a Catholic issue or they were in support of àbôrtîôn rates
but since then
we've seen a very successful fusion of being Republican with being uh
this sort of like conservative evangelical coated family values type identity
okay so that's the first one
the second one is the increase of people in the United States
and across western countries generally
who are no longer identifying with mainstream Christianity
or mainstream religion
that's been a steady development since like the nineties
but in 2020
survey data showed that the number of evangelicals in the United States
were going up
so evangelicals saw this data and they were like
oh my god we're doing such a good job
we're just bringing everyone to Christ
but that's not actually what's happening
something much stranger is happening
this was panel survey data
so what that means is that they surveyed people in
I think 2016 and then they went back and they surveyed them again in 2020
asking them the same questions
and what they found was that people who identified as secular
or as a different religion from Protestant Christianity
were now identifying as evangelical
their identities had shifted
so political scientist Ryan Burge uh
thinks that the reason that this is happening is twofold
so for the secular people who are now identifying as evangelical
he thinks that because it correlates statistically with uh
partisan identity
that to be Republican now for some people means to be evangelical
and so to claim the title of evangelical even as a secular person is to say
I believe I'm a Republican
I but I'm an evangelical
I'm a Republican
he thinks the reason that other religious people are identifying as evangelical
now in addition to whatever religious persuasion they are
is different from just that partisan identity
that's happening with secular people who are identifying as evangelical
and what he thinks is happening there
is that people are understanding the term evangelical
as meaning someone of deeply held religious
and probably conservative beliefs
but in other words
someone who is a Buddhist says
I'm a Buddhist
but I'm also an evangelical
because I strongly believe in the teachings of the Buddha
but we don't actually know this is based off of statistical correlations
we need to actually be going out and asking people
why are you what's
what's going on here
like tell me more about this
so that's research that's really exciting and needs to happen
but I would love to hear your thoughts on this
I'm super fascinated by these findings
and I think that they probably have a lot of um
importance for the upcoming election
but also if you're someone who's secular or a different religion
who's now identifying as evangelical
please tell me why and be very interesting to learn from you